رغم مرور سنوات طويله على واقع جمعهن تحت
مسمى لاجئات الا ان الوقت لا يزال صعبا
وفي تحدي الوقت هذه المره استطعنا تشكيل
اجمل المجسمات من الصلصال ايام قليله
ابدعت فيها سيدات الزعتري في اكتساب اسرار
هذه الحرفه التي كانت واحده من ضمن دورات
عديده وفعاليات تابعه لمركز الملك سلمان
للاغاثه والاعمال الانسانيه كثير اعطتنا
طاقه ايجابيه كثير طلعنا اللي جواتنا
الشغلات السلبيه يعني واستمتعنا واحنا
نشتغل بالعجين يعني وكان يعني شغل ممتع
جدا من اول لقاء بيني وبينهم البسمه كانت
على وجيههم التفاؤل فحمسوني بدينا نشتغل
بديت اعلمهم على الطين وايش الانواع كانوا
اكثر قابليه وتقبل للفن 40 متطوعا توسعوا
على عشره مشاريع تعنى بتنميه الموارد
البشريه في مخيم الزعتري في وقت فتحت
خدمات الطبيه ابوابها لاهل المخيم خدمات
تعنى بحياه اللاجئين وصولا لدعمهم النفسي
والاسري نحن وفقنا في خلال هذا الاسبوع
بفحص اكثر من 290 حاله ومقاربه 300 حالف
كان معنا تخصصات العظام طبعا معايا
والعلاج الطبيعي كفريق متعاون مع قسم
العظام وقسم الجلديه والاطفال سواء طوارئ
او عيادات تضمنت هذه البرامج مشاركه فرق
طبيه بعيادات طبيه وكذلك تدريب الكوادر
الطبيه هنا في المخيم كذلك تضمنت لمشاريع
الدعم وتمكين الاقتصادي والتي استهدفت
صناعه الصابون وصناعه الفخار ومجال صيانه
الحاسب الالي والخياطه والتطريز والتي
بالاشك تعود عليهم كعائد اقتصادي جيد هنا
في المخيم برامج تطوعيه لم تغفل عن جيلا
صغيرا قدم معظم سنوات حياته بعيدا عن
الوطن لكنه اليوم يمضي ايامه ضمن فعاليات
وورش تعليميه وترفيهيه باتت عرفا سنويا
تقليدا يقدمه مركز الملك سلمان لابنائي
مخيم الزعتري من مخيم الزعتري شمال
العاصمه عمان سهى جميل العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات